Maxie talks okay you handy
all right sounds good yes thanks so much
for the introduction yes so today I'm
going to be talking about the QA Oh a
from a bit of a different perspective
this is from kind of the theoretical
computer science perspective and what
I'm going to be looking at today is you
know to what extent does the QA Oh a
offer a speed-up over classical methods
and kind of what's the right way that we
should measure the speed up and and
what's kind of the fair comparison that
we should be making the classical
algorithms when we're trying to
understand the structure of cue AOA and
this potential for for speed ups so
maybe our first inclination as
theoretical computer science would be to
try to perform could would be to try to
compare the performance of cue AOA on
approximation problems like max cut and
say take this performance and compare it
to the best possible classical
algorithms
and if we take this particular standard
for establishing a quantum speed-up for
QA then thus far we have not been able
to see any any speed ups or any
worst-case performance guarantees for
the QA o a of over classical algorithms
so for example if we consider you know
the paramedic case of the max cut
problem you have some graph and you want
to cut the maximum number of edges
possible by making a by partition of the
graph you know there is a classic result
of Gilman's and williamson that says
that you can get a zero point eight
seven eight you know approximation to
the best possible max cut in polynomial
time using a very clever SDP algorithm
and then a randomized rounding scheme on
top of the algorithm and then in
comparison if you look at the QA OS
performance for instance on three
regular graphs three regular triangle
free graphs what far he goes some
Gottman show than their original paper
was that they are able to get zero point
six nine two four aprox or something
like this right for P equals one yes
exactly yes another difficulty here is
that the QA becomes increasingly
difficult to Ann to analyze by hand as
the p-values increase so it's it's
usually a lot of times let's analyzes a
relatively low p-value where you can
then make explicit formulas for the the
QoS performance okay all right so if you
take okay so this is what happens at P
equals one maybe at P equals two it
might improve we know that as P
increases the QA OS performance will get
better and better a natural question is
then well is there at some point at
which the QA o a is going to say match
the Gulman Williamson's algorithms
performance or possibly even they exceed
it right and in this case for worst case
performance guarantees there have been
some results I have been saying that
you'll make
maybe thus this might not be possible in
terms of worst-case performance
guarantees and the results are kind of
due to two different sorts of
perspectives so the first perspective is
a perspective of the unique games
conjecture and the unique games
conjecture is it's it's a conjecture
that some particular problem is np-hard
but it turns out there's a well-known
result that says that if the unique
games conjecture is true then it means
that getting a point eight seven eight
you know whoever plus epsilon
approximation is np-hard or any constant
epsilon greater than zero okay so of
course the unique games conjecture
remains unproven there has been some
partial progress towards resolving some
special cases of a unique games
conjecture called the to-to-to games
conjecture that was proven a few years
ago but this is some evidence that maybe
the queue AOA might not be able to
surpass this barrier unless of course
you believe you know quantum computers
are capable of solving unique games
hard' or np-hard problems right now of
course it would be nice to you know it
would be nice to prove such a thing that
the queue AOA would never you know a
better performance guarantees and in the
special case of maxcut there actually
was a recent result that stated that
this is this case so for instance there
was a recent result of bravi Fleisch
Koenig and Tang just from last October
which saw the results that was somewhat
of the following form what they said is
that for any P which is less than order
log n then P level Q AOA
the best ratio it achieves for maxcut is
less than equal to 5/6 plus some
quantity which is order 1 over root
capital D and here capital D is just the
is just the degree of the graph so sorry
let me be a little more precise of what
they said what they said is that there
exists you know a family of instances of
Max gun such that the following holds so
these are particularly kind of difficult
instances for the QIO a and what they
show this at you know if you just ramp D
up then the approximation ratio that
this algorithm will achieve
will be something that looks like
something point eight three three yes
I don't know if the top my head actually
it's a good question
yes okay so what this was kind of saying
was that okay if you're really talking
about worst-case performance guarantees
for max gonnigan max cut that's not the
only optimization problem we care about
though you know it's it's a reasonable
and very well studied example then we
actually have some evidence that the QA
Oh a at least that low depths you know
will not be able to beat gunman's
williamson or say the the best SVP
algorithms okay yeah of course at first
i think if you look at the bravi paper
which of course is very nice
is less than a small constant times log
n yes yes is such that when you look at
the sub graphs they don't cover the
whole thing we've always suspected that
if you don't see the whole graph you're
not going to be able yeah because of
locality of course yes bounded degree
graphs and P is less than a constant
which goes like 1 over the D I think
like that so that you know yes but if
you make the custom big enough so that
you see the whole graph they don't have
a result okay thanks for clarification
yes but for constant depth it certainly
is as a barrier definitely yes exactly
okay great yeah so this is kind of yeah
so so this was kind of one result kind
of indicating that there could be some
limitations to the QA Oh a but you know
this you know another kind of natural
question you can ask after seeing that
results it's kind of you know is this
actually a fair comparison right in some
sense you can look at the you can look
at these SDP approximation algorithms of
Gilman's Williamson you know these are
in some sense some of the crown jewels
of theoretical computer science right
like they're based on the fact there's
even a polynomial time algorithm to
solve SDPs in the first place is not
obvious and the choice of these
relaxations is particularly clever on
the other hand we're racing these very
fancy SDPs against you know something
like constant depth quantum circuits
which is a extremely weak model of
computation right so this is why you
know in
sometimes you know Eddie and his talks
mentions that you know there there was
one particular problem for which cue AOA
briefly had an advantage over the best
possible classical algorithms and I like
Eddie's phrase that the classical SDP
people came and then and then beat up
the QA Oh a you know because all ganged
up on him and in some sense you know
using kind of these beautiful and rich
mathematical tools that have been
developed from TCS so this kind of begs
the question is there a more fair
comparison that we can make in order to
try to understand the power of the cue
aoa and in other words like what is the
right sort of subset of classical
algorithms that are more analogous to
what the cue aoa is doing and maybe we
can look at those and try to examine
with those whether or not there is that
there's a computational speed up against
those algorithms and this was precisely
the suggestion of a recent paper of
Hastings from 2019 and what Hastings
suggested is that the right thing to
compare to is is that we should be
comparing to something that he calls
local classical algorithms all right so
when there's a local classical algorithm
let me give you a kind of brief
definition of this let's say that AP
level d dimensional local classical
algorithm let's say for but let's say
for the max cut problem for the for the
movement though we'll generalize this to
more general sorts of optimization
problems it looks something like this
so for each vertex I
we'll give it some value VI which is
lives in some D dimensional space okay
and let's say we initialize the values
you know the first stage of the
algorithm is that we initialize them you
know we set each VI independently you
know according to some particular
distribution and then we have another
rule which is that we're going to define
like a local update rule and what the
local update rule will be something like
this we'll take each value you know each
vertex now contains a d-dimensional
vector what we're going to do is we're
going to take each VI and then we'll
replace it by some function of VI as
well as the V eyes of its its neighbors
in the graph right so this is kind of a
locally defined update rule so or so
I'll call this bj 1 bj 2 you know up to
BJD where the J the J I are the
neighbors of AI
in the graph G okay and then what we'll
do is we'll just kind of repeat this
local update rule P times
and then what we'll do is at the end you
know what performs some sort of rounding
scheme at the end because we'll need
some way of taking these d dimensional
vectors that we kind of been mixing
locally in the graph and then converting
in back to plus minus 1 values for the
Mexica algorithm now the natural the
nice thing about this sort of algorithm
is that it's it's quite clearly a
classical analog of the queue ãoã right
because what's happening in the queue
ãoã is that as Eddie was talking about
in his talk is that if you want
evaluates performance for low values of
P it ends up only kind of the
performance of the algorithm only
depends on the P local neighborhoods of
the graph that that it's being defined
on and similarly the performance of
these local classical algorithms is also
only a function of the P local
neighborhoods as well because after P
iterations of the algorithm you know the
values of the VI you know only depend on
the values of the VI assigned to the
initial neighbors so this is kind of a I
I really like this suggestion because I
think it's really capturing a little
more of what's going on in the Q AOA and
a little more of its structure more than
saying an SDP comparison okay now the
question that Hastings said asked is
then okay the natural clashes then you
know does the QA Oh a have a speed up
against these against these local
classical algorithms
now of course yield these local classic
algorithms you know on the one hand
they're a very restricted class of
algorithms on the other hand there is
some richness there you know what
distributions do you pick what rounding
scheme do you pick how do you mix your
kind of vis and as you make these local
update rules okay so actually no
analyzing this in general is quite hard
but what these things actually showed is
that he could actually create a one
dimensional local classical algorithm
for the max cut problem that at P equals
one actually outperforms the P equals 1
Q AOA on Mac Scott so this was the this
was Hastings main result in his paper he
actually gave two results the first one
is that the first was that there exists
a P equals 1 B equals 1 local classical
algorithm or max cut which outperforms P
equals 1 Q AOA for all D between 2 and
the thousand so there's actually the
regularity the graph plays a role except
D is 3 4 6 or 11 so and I'll explain why
why this might have occurred there and
for these you know there exists another
algorithm you know there exists another
slightly more complicated
algorithm that that that that plug plugs
these holes in then D equals 3 4 6 and
11 ok so what this is saying well this
is saying that you know maybe the story
here is is you know it's quite rich so
ok and P equals 1 we actually what this
is saying is that there's there's
actually not a speed-up of classical
line of QA Oh a against classical
algorithms but you know I think that
it's actually giving rise to a large
number of questions to be asked about
whether for higher P things like this
will still occur or kind of at what
values of P should the QA Oh a start to
pull away I as people were mentioning at
very high values of P you start to be
able to do can I have Trotter eyes
adiabatic computation so maybe there
should be some grover like speed ups or
things like this that will occur at
higher P but you know what's happening
at low or P you know can be quite
different than what one expects at high
P so it's kind of saying that that
there's that there's some interesting
questions here so I'm going to briefly
describe these things algorithm and you
know and after I describe the algorithm
I'll be able to explain why kind of why
this exception occurred in kind of the
general form of the the advantage for
firm Act cut that you end up getting out
of the algorithm all right so what's the
algorithm the algorithm is extremely
simple
so what Hastings algorithm does is it
says ok initially we're going to set
each VI to be uniformly a plus minus 1
value at random so just at the behavior
algorithm I'm just going to pick every
spin independently at random and you
know the expected value of the max cuts
is in this case is 1/2 right so so the
expected number of edges cut
it's just M over two if M is the number
of edges right okay so now what's the
update rule going to be well let's
define a simple function I'm going to
define a function called F I think of
this is as the force on vertex I that'd
be that kind of the neighbors of the
vertex are exerting on it trying to
pressure it to flip its sign
so what's Fi I'm gonna write it more
formally it's a product of VI and the
sum over edges in the graph over
adjacent vertices of the BJ value so
just the kind of think this out you know
because I put this on the plus minus one
basis you know if there were an equal
number of neighbors that were plus one
and minus one this would be zero right
so there there'd be no force to flip but
on the other hand you know if you had
more neighbors that were Plus Ones and
minus ones this this would be positive
at valued so if you were positive value
as well this would this would give you a
positive force that that you should be
flipping your sign right and conversely
if you were already negative and most of
your neighbors were positive then this
would be telling you you know there'd be
a negative force it would kind of be
telling you to stay put right and the
basic algorithm is now the most simple
one the basic algorithm is that you pick
a threshold T pick an integer threshold
and what you're going to do is that
you're going to independently and
simultaneously you're going to flip
vertex I if the force on it is more than
T this is the this is the entire
algorithm and you just do this in one
step so this is one thing to note here
is that actually all these flips are
happening in parallel it's not like you
you're you aren't doing a sweep across
the graph where you decide to flip each
one in in series but rather this is all
happening simultaneously in parallel
yes it could it could improve if you do
is a sweet but I don't know if it would
get an asymptotic improvement over what
they achieve okay so this is the all
right so are there any questions about
the Hastings algorithm
so the analysis of the algorithm is
relatively straightforward so how do you
prove up the performance guarantee of
this algorithm for a particular
threshold T well the analysis is again
using the fact that this algorithm is
local so you can apply a very q AO a
like analysis to the algorithm so you
know the expected value of the cut is
you know just the sum of the expected
value of each edge so we by linearity we
can just look at what's happening with a
single edge IJ of the graph and then
what we then do is you say okay you know
let's say it's a triangle free max cut
instance so each of these edges is
connected to D minus 1 disjoint
neighbors and the intuition here is that
if you look at the sum of D minus 1 plus
minus 1 random variables you know this
is a random walk right so for large D
this thing will be distributed basically
as a Gaussian random variable right so
the sum of the neighbors is will be some
Gaussian of mean 0 and the variance will
be D minus 1 so so the standard
deviation is this is Sigma squared so
the standard deviation will be typically
of order root D and when Hastings kind
of numerically optimize okay so yeah
when Hastings numerically optimize the
algorithm what he found is that this
threshold T basically ends up being some
small constant times roughly square root
D okay so what does this mean this means
that basically in this algorithm because
as these things are gaussians of
standard deviation root D you know this
means actually in this update step where
you flip some of the vertices you're
going to flip a small constant fraction
of the edges right so they're a so
a small constant fraction of the edges
will be flipped by the algorithm okay
and then if you take a look at okay so a
small constant fraction sorry of the
vertices will be flipped now we want to
know kind of what fraction of the time
will that actually take our edge IJ from
being uncut to being cut right that
that's the only question that that we
need to answer to analyze this algorithm
and here the basic idea for analyzing it
is using kind of an idea of conditional
independence so what what do I mean by
this well let's imagine that you know in
this algorithm you're drawing one
Gaussian value here right and another
Gaussian value here let's just say that
at the end of the algorithm this vertex
I is at plus one and let's focus on what
happens with vertex J in the in the
algorithm well if this Gaussian were
drawn such that the force on it was very
far from the threshold already I think I
have no matter what happens to vertex I
or no matter what the value of vertex I
is relative to J it will end up changing
the the outcome of the flip right so
there won't there won't be any gain but
the basic intuition is that there is
kind of an order 1 over root D
probability that's on the on the other
hand there's some very small probability
but something that only goes as 1 over
root D that this this value is actually
right at the threshold so if this is the
case then it means that the value of I
is then casting the deciding vote in in
what the value of J will be right and if
the value of I cast the deciding vote
then that means that that the edge will
certainly be cut right so this is the
probability that I
the deciding boot lip Jay and this is
the only case in which this this this
implies that the edge is cut by the
algorithm when the kind of what would
not have been cut in the random
assignment so what this ends up giving
you is this ends up giving your your
your but you can show very easily is
that then the expected number of edges
cut will be roughly equal to M times 1/2
plus something that's order 1 over root
D now this is actually the precise
performance of P equals 1 Q AOA when you
apply it to D regular Mexico this wall
has exactly this 1 over root D
performance improvement over random
guessing now what Hastings then did is
he sings then you know numerically
optimize the threshold with his computer
for each individual value of D you know
just by brute forcing over all possible
assignments to to do these D local grass
right you know you know exact you know
you don't actually have to brute-force
over to D plus 1 things of course right
all you care about is what's the the
weight of the vertices here in the
weight of the vs. here how many ones and
zeroes aren't ones and minus ones there
are but that's the that that's the
essential analysis and it just happens
to so be that that the constant you get
over this root D is is actually higher
than the Q AOA algorithm except for
these D equals 3 4 6 11 cases and now I
can tell you why this these exceptions
occurred right these exceptions occurred
just because summing three random
variables is not a very good
approximation to a Gaussian it turns out
three plus minus 1 variables similarly 3
4 6 11 you kind of get unlucky in the
way your discrete approximation to the
Gaussian kind of behaves for those kind
of exceptional numbers such that the the
performance constant the constant you
get here ends up being worse than what's
achieved for QA Oh a but this is this is
essentially
this is essentially the result and okay
good okay so great so the question is
how do you fix it well the way that you
fix it is with a minor tweak instead of
drawing each vertex to be a plus minus
one variable you draw it uniformly in
the interval minus one one and then you
perform a real mix between it and now
you have a real constant coefficient
that you can tune and then he showed you
you can tune it like that of course it's
a great question what happens with other
distributions but this is one of the
first ones you would think of it I think
Hastings wrote that explicitly his paper
that this was just the first one that he
tried to fix it and it happened to work
yeah yes
yes well these things discussed this
analysis that this is yes I should say
this entire talk is a survey so this is
none of this is my work so Hastings yeah
already discussed this analysis that's
order routine that the threshold should
you know should be some constant times
root D in terms of why it should be the
constant that appeared this I'm not sure
that there was kind of an insight into
this though it did is if he you know
there if you plot what this constant
threshold is over over time with D it
does actually kind of asymptotes you
know to some limiting value but ya know
it's a great question okay good alright
so that was Hastings result and moreover
he also applied it to another problem
which is the max three eel in two
problem or also max 3x or so his second
his second result was something like or
for the problem of max 3x or then
there's also a P equals one D equals one
local classical algorithm
which kind of beats random guessing
by some amount which scale says one over
D to the 3/4 and this is similar for
context if you take P equals 1 Q AOA
then in the original paper where they
did this with some kind of instance
independent parameters then this was the
original speed up as well it also got 1
over D to the 3/4 advantage over random
guessing you know 4 4 or 4 P equals 1 of
course it turns out that if you make a
non-local or instance dependent choice
of parameters then you know far eagleson
Guttman showed subsequently that this
could be improved to 1 over root D so
this this is stronger will be root D log
D exactly yeah where is the best
classical is what is 1 over root D but
is essentially the same so what this
will show is that you know again in this
framework you know it's actually
somewhat rich you're able to reproduce
some of the properties that we've seen
arising in q AOA at least at the P
equals 1 level and was fairly kind of
the the most basic forms of Q AOA that
we can explicitly analyze so I think
that these works are really interesting
because they're kind of pointing us
towards a lot of fascinating questions
for instance you know okay so we so far
we haven't been able to see any speed
ups of the Q AOA for P equals 1 against
these local classical algorithms you
know is there some higher value of P in
which Q AOA pulls ahead you know is
there a method of proving lower bounds
against these forms of local classical
algorithms that that can kind of inhibit
their performance but not inhibit the
performance of the Q AOA which of course
also has the same local structure so I
think that this is these are salts
really interesting because they're just
pointing that to a lot of interesting
problems in this in this area which we
can definitely discuss more over the in
the discussion periods Thanks
[Applause]
we'll be discussed during the discussion
session so just as a curio is remain
reminiscent of anybody's quantum
computing yes exactly and at the high P
limit it will it can reproduce simulated
annealing right it's it's rich enough
uses a probabilistic update rule so
here's the terminus - yes yes I so I
think that in the be most general
formulation he wrote in the paper he did
allow probabilistic updates and then
probabilistic rounding in which case yes
then it does just reproduce kind of
simulated annealing in the limit so this
is in some sense it's very analogous to
what's happening with with the cue AOA
high P - yeah thanks for putting that
out exactly it's facially distributed
but once you get up once you go beyond
the end and you're kind of seeing the
whole graph and the algorithm if you go
to very high depths that then I think it
can just reproduce reproduce simulation
like